certain dialogue.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Il y a une personne proche
de moi qui a posé des gestes
à caractère sexuel sur moi
sans mon consentement
quand j'étais plus jeune.
- Des personnes qui ont vécu
des violences xuxuelles
et qui en subissent
encore les séquelles.
- Pendant trois jours,
j'ai comme fixé le mur, puis
je ne pouvais plus manger,
je ne pouvais plus boire.
J'étais complètement en état
de choc. J'ai eu des pensées
aussi... comme suicidaires,
je suis allée en centrededede c.
- D'autres qui se sont retrouvés
dans le rôle d'agresseur.
MARIE-EVE LAMOUREUX, directrice
générale, organisme Équijustice
- Sur les listes qui ont sorti à
travers #MeToo, il y a certains
auteurs qui se sont retrouvés
sur ces listes-là.
- Ils reconnaissent parfois
qu'ils ont fait quelque chose,
mais ils cherchent à être
accompagnés pour bien le faire.
- Quand des victimes et
des agresseurs acceptent
volontaintntnt de réparer
les torts, accompagnées
par un médiateur,
c'est ce qu'on appelle
la justice réparatrice.
- On va dire la justice
réparatrice, moi, j'aime
bien utiliser le terme,
c'est fait sur mesure.
- Car le processus varie
selon le but recherché
par la victime.
- Souvent, elles ont été
en thérapie, elles ont fait
un bon bout de chemin, puis,
bien, pour certaines d'entre
elles, il e e e e clé
qui leur manque pour
continuer d'aller mieux.
Mon packsack, j'aimerais ça que
ce soit l'autre qui le porte.
- Le processus ne se termine pas
forcément par une rencontre,
mais lorsque c'est le cas,
il y a toujours un médiateur
présent pour veiller notamment
à la sécurité des échanges.
- Le but, c'est pas de dire
qu'on s'en va en médiation
pour trouver des compromis.
Il n'y a pas de...
Dans le sens qu'il n'y a pas
de compromis sur ce qui s'est
passé : j'ai été victime.
Mais comment on en parle,
comment on nomme les choses,
comment on fait ce processus-là,
bien, on décide ensemble.
- David-Mathieu a fini
par rencontrer le proche
qui l'a agressé sexuellement
alors qu'il était mineur.
Mais plusieurs séances
de préparation seul à seul
avec la médiatrice ont précédé
la rencontre à trois.
- Moi, je l'ai vécu comme
quelque chose d'assez intense,
donc je... c'est pas...
Oui, c'est réparateur mais je te
dirais pas que c'était agréable!
C'était pas plaisant, là.
Ma colère a eu une place dans...
dans ce que j'ai partagé et
dans... la colère de dire :
c'est ça, t'sais, c'est ça
que tu m'as fait, c'est ça,
les gestes que tu as posés,
mais après, regarde,
c'est ça que j'ai vécu.
- Beaucoup de victimes
d'agression sexuelle
choissisent de
se tourner vers les tribunaux.
Celle que nous appellerons
Carmen a aussi voulu donner
une chance à la justicepapapapas
parallèle au système
judiciaire criminel.
- Je voulais pas que lui...
admettons, il so
comme délinquant, c'est pas ça
du tout, du tout. Pas la prison,
pas qu'il paye... c'est pas ça.
Mais qu'il fasse... qu'il soit
aidé... qu'il soit accompagné
aussi pour que, finalement,
ça ne se reproduise plus,
t'sais, ça, c'était quelque
chose que je recherchais.
- Il y a plein de raisons pour
lesquelles quelqu'un peut avoir
fait son parcours judiciaire
régulier et veut se saisir
de la justice réparatrice,
soit parce qu'effectivement,
les accusations n'ont pas été
retenues ou parce qu'à terme
des procédures, la personne
a pu être déclarée coupable,
mais la justice répara
n'étant pas prévue à l'heure
actuelle pour un adulte, bien,
la personne victime veut quand
même être dans une situation
où elle voudrait discuter.
- Équijustice est un des rares
organismes qui se spécialisent
en justice réparatrice et
qui a développé une expertise
pour les cas d'agression
sexuelle depuis 2017,
depuis le mouvement #MeToo.
- De quelques demandes
par année, on est rendu à p
d'une centaine de personnes
dans les dernières années qui
nous contactent en disant :
"Est-ce que ça peut être
possible pour moi?"
- La médiation peut parfois
être offerte dans l
judiciaire criminel, mais pas
pour les cas d'agression
sexuelle, ce qui pourrait
être appelé à changer,
selon cett
Me ISABELLE BRIAND, avocate-
criminaliste et médiatrice
- Il y a une demande à cet
effet-là, les victimes demandent
en matière d'agression sexuelle
et je ne vois pas pourquoi
la loi n'irait pas en ce sens.
- Un terrain trop glissant
pour cette a
RACHEL CHAGNON, professeure,
Dép. sciences juridiques UQAM
- Il faut jamais perdre de vue
qu'on a décidé collectivement
quand même que l'agression
sexuelle, c'était un acte
criminel. Si la justice
réparatrice devenait
une alternative au processus
pénal, il y aurait quand mêmenoe
que les agresseurs
se lancent là-dedans pas
pour les meilleures raisons.
- Surtout qu'actuellement,
la justice réparat
se fait de façon volontaire
dans ces cas précis. Carmen
n'a justement pas pu aller
jusqu'au bout du processus.
- S'il ne veut pas répondre,
il ne répondra pas, fait
qu'il reprend encore du pouvoir.
Puis c'est ça qu'il s'est passé
aussi avec moi. C'est clairement
pas tous les cas que ça...
bien, voilà, le mien est un bon
exemple, il faut nuancer aussi.
C'est pas la baguette magique.
- Néanmoins, c'est ce quileleles
à David-Mathieu.
- Ça m'a permis de reprendre
du pouvoir. L'image que moi...
qui fait du sens
c'est de dire que j'avais
une blessure infectée. Puis là,
on l'a pansée, je l'ai recousue.
Je comprends qu'est-ce qui est
arrivé, je comprends comment
m'en occuper, puis ça va de
mieux en mieux, ça me dérange
de moins en moins, mais...
il y a pas... t'sais,
ça va rester là